un déluge de feu
il est 4 heures 20 saint denis en
banlieue nord de paris
lorsque débute l'assaut d'une violence
extrême comme en témoignent ces images
captées par des voisins
les policiers ont tiré plus de cinq
mille balles ces résidentes habite à un
coin de rue elles n'ont pas dormi de la
nuit la police partout et joe il ya des
fusillades partie en attente de la bande
si même pas qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
à dire aller en guerre qu'est ce qui se
passe on n'a jamais vu ça vraiment là
j'en ai besoin
c'est la guerre qui était
des plantes est retranché dans un
appartement
les présumés terroristes ont résisté
avec acharnement femme s'est même fait
exploser une femme kamikaze
une première en france il s'agirait de
la cousine d'abdelhamid about le cerveau
présumé des attentats de vendredi
l'homme que visait le raid
au final au moins deux présumés
terroristes sont morts et sept personnes
ont été arrêtées dont le propriétaire de
l'appartement qui nie tout lien avec ses
occupants baj appris que c'était chez
moi et que les individus se retrancher
chez moi et que j'étais pas consulté
rose
les suspects recherchés ne se trouve pas
parmi les personnes arrêtées pendant de
longues heures le centre-ville de
saint-denis reste donc bouclé encerclée
par plusieurs centaines de policiers
lourdement armés et très nerveux même si
l'aso principal est terminée la traque
se poursuit beaucoup de fausses alertes
cependant les hommes d'élite de la
police nationale vient de casser la
porte de l'église
ils n'ont rien trouvé ils partent
ailleurs
le souffle de l'explosion a été terrible
l'immeuble est ravagée le plancher
menace de s'écrouler ce qui complique le
travail de la police scientifique
et pourtant il faut aller vite pour
faire avancer l'enquêté
les autorités sont convaincues qu'un
autre attentat est en préparation
l'aéroport de roissy est le quartier des
affaires de la défense figurait parmi
les cibles visées
tout laisse à penser que au regard de
leurs armes au nom de leur organisation
structurée et de leur détermination
ce commando pouvait passer à l'acte
selon les autorités françaises
plus de 800 policiers enquêtent
présentement sur les attentats de
vendredi 13
objectif remonter jusqu aux
organisateurs aux commanditaires
éradiquer les réseaux bref tout faire
vaut prévenir d'autres actions du même
genre même si et les français le savent
le risque de nouvelles attaques restent
très élevés ici jean françois bélanger
radio-canada saint denis